[Musique]
je suis pas venu jusqu'ici juste pour
filmer les chaînes Myriam corner mais
disons que ça rend l'entrevue
sympathique
Myriam c'est une Allemande qui s'est
accrochée les pieds dans un petit
village qui bordent un immense lac on
est à l'arrange à 400 km au nord de
saskato
ça veut dire tourbières un milieu humide
qui est dominé par la mousse on sait
qu'on est dans une tourbière tout de
suite en y mettant les pieds
sur un gâteau éponge sur des couches et
des couches de mousse c'est pour ça que
je voulais rencontrer Myriam parce
qu'elle se bat pour un des écosystèmes
les plus importants pour l'équilibre de
la planète mais qui laisse la plupart
d'entre nous indifférents peu de gens
savent qu'on est assis sur un
climatiseur gigantesque qui refroidit et
stabilise le climat en absorbant du CO2
les tourbières couvrent seulement 3% de
la surface de la planète mais stock
environ 30% de tout le carbone contenu
dans le sol c'est plus que tous les
arbres de toutes les forêts du monde
réunis
le Canada est un des pays les plus
riches en tourbières le quart des
ressources mondiales se trouve chez nous
planter des arbres c'est bien pour
absorber du CO2 mais il faut savoir
qu'un mètre carré de tourbières contient
environ 5 fois plus de carbone qu'un
mètre carré de forêt en plus de le
garder dans le sol plus longtemps durant
des millénaires c'est aussi ce que fait
Orca la plus grande machine de capture
de carbone au monde en Islande sauf
qu'elle a coûté 15 millions de dollars
et qu'il en faudrait 30 000 pour capter
tout le CO2 que les tourbières
canadiennes séquestrent gratuitement
mais cette paix menacée les tourbières
renferme aussi une ressource convoitée
la tourbe à ne pas confondre avec les
rouleaux de pelouse la tourbe c'est ce
qui se trouve sous le tapis de mousse
d'une tour bière de la vieille matière
végétale qu'on mélange à des éléments
nutritifs pour en faire toutes sortes de
terreaux articules la compagnie Lambert
une pionnière québécoise de la récolte
de tourbes projette dans récolter sur de
grandes parcelles ici à la range pendant
près de 100 ans
myriam a fondé un groupe citoyen pour
s'opposer au projet
[Musique]
il y en a des belles tourbières dans le
nord du moins alors pourquoi une
compagnie québécoise qu'on voit des
tourbières en Saskatchewan pour mieux
comprendre il faut fouiller dans les
archives
[Musique]
on peut faire un paquet de choses avec
de la tourbe fabriquer des maisons
l'utiliser pour se chauffer comme on l'a
longtemps fait en Angleterre en fait
c'est une des premières formes de
combustible fossiles parce qu'une
tourbière c'est une usine à sephène ces
petites mousses qui poussent comme un
tapis qui s'auto tricote vers le haut
sous le tapis c'est vraiment mouillé qui
a très peu d'oxygène ce qui fait que les
sphinx se décomposent très lentement
elle s'empile à un rythme d'un
millimètre par année une tourbière de 4
mètres de profondeur comme on en trouve
un peu partout au pays contient 4000 ans
de carbone fossiles
des squelettes de sphing ça absorbe très
bien l'eau c'est notamment pour ça qu'on
l'utilise en horticulture depuis
longtemps au pays surtout au Québec et
au niveau brandswick on a industrialisé
la méthode traditionnelle et le Canada
est maintenant le premier exportateur de
tourbe en terme de valeur dans le monde
à l'orange les traditions on est sur le
territoire d'une des plus grandes
premières nations du pays les cris des
bois les cours de Christine se donnent
en plein air ces étudiants apprennent
les rudiments de la vie nordique
de la communauté qui connaît tous les
secrets des plantes médicinales
[Musique]
si vous aimez jardiner vous vous
demandez peut-être si votre passion est
responsable de la destruction des
tourbières mais ça se joue surtout à
grande échelle il faut savoir que plus
de 90% de la tour canadienne est
exportée aux États-Unis et que 70% de la
tourbe est utilisée n'ont pas par des
particuliers mais par des producteurs de
légumes ou de plantes ornementales
parcelles au sud de la ronge à récolter
de manière séquentielle pendant 80 à 100
ans
un total de 2600 hectares de tourbières
soit le corps de la superficie qui est
actuellement exploitée au Québec
le projet se trouve dans l'habitat du
caribou forestier qui est menacé
notamment par les activités
industrielles comme la foresterie la
communauté craint aussi pour son nom
parce que les milieux turbules sont à la
fois des filtres et des réservoirs à eau
lombaire a jamais répondu à mes demandes
d'entrevue mais Marie-Claire Leblanc qui
représente les producteurs de tourbes
m'a donné plus de détails
pour être capable d'avoir la machinerie
qui va sur la tourbière qui est capable
de circuler puis d'extraire donc par
aspiration mais il faut que la tourne
soit très très sèche donc pour drainer
la surface il faut s'assurer que après
ça avec le vent le soleil on attend puis
on récolte la tour quand c'est quand
c'est sec
la tourbière peut rester ouverte comme
ça durant 30 40 ans la tourbe exposée se
met à émet du carbone et joue plus son
rôle habituel de pare-feu
tout le monde se souvient de fort
mcmurerie en 2016 qui a brûlé pendant
plus d'un an des scientifiques ont
établi un lien entre l'assèchement de
milieu humide dans les environs et la
sévérité de l'incendie
l'atome sèche peut aussi devenir un
brasier potentiel c'est arrivé en 2020
dans le camouraska quand le feu a pris
dans une des tourbières de l'envers
mais comme dans la vie tout n'est pas
tout noir ni tout blanc ici donc l'été
96 il y avait de la récolte tout ça
toute la tourbière à l'époque elle était
ouverte elle était en extraction il y
avait des machines qui se promenaient
l'industrie restaure les sites après
l'extraction de la tourbe en lisant avec
une petite quantité de sphinx et en
redirigeant l'eau sur place donc si ça a
été restauré pour moi c'est un succès
phénoménal toutes les arbres sont là
c'est des espèces qu'on voudrait que tu
sois là dans des densités qui sont super
intéressantes cette technique on
l'utilise partout dans le monde et elle
a été développée au Québec par la
chercheuse line Rochefort de
l'Université Laval quand j'ai écrit
Aline pour mieux connaître la science de
la restauration on m'a plutôt référé à
Marie-Claire qui a pas toujours
travaillé pour l'industrie donc pendant
au groupe de recherche en écologie des
tourbières à l'Université Laval et
j'étais professionnel de recherche
là-bas
la science la restauration des
tourbières c'est un petit monde
notamment parce que l'industrie finance
les études sur la restauration depuis
plus de 30 ans en fait elle est
pratiquement à l'origine de champ de
recherche là c'est assez rare qu'une
industrie qui extrait une ressource du
sol restaure les sites que le perturbé
mais après des décennies d'exploitation
les tourbières mettent du temps à
retrouver leur fonction naturelle
la végétation de tourbière revient à peu
près 3 à 5 ans après la restauration on
sait que les fonctions de séquestration
du carbone reviennent à l'intérieur de
15 ans puis pour le carbone ancien en
fait ce qu'on est allé récolter ça prend
combien de temps avant de le récupérer
on sait que c'est long les chiffres on
le sait pas encore
dans le labo de Michel Garnot on analyse
la tourbe c'est une spécialiste du
stockage de carbone par les tourbières
ça prend combien de temps en fait pour
retrouver du carbone qu'on irait
chercher sous terre est-ce qu'on peut le
retrouver ce carbone non c'est sûr que
le carbone si par exemple il y a un
mètre ou deux mètres de tourbe qui a été
exploité ce carbone là
va prendre des millénaires à se
reconstruire au complet par contre quand
une tourbière est restaurée la tourbière
va recommencer à faire de la
photosynthèse et va être capable de
continuer de maintenir cette fonction-là
d'absorption du CO2 atmosphérique donc
on est un pays de mousse on est assis
sur un gros climatiseur à peu près oui
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour protéger ses
écosystèmes-là au Canada ce qu'il faut
faire s'il faut arriver il y a des
politiques de conservation extrêmement
rigoureuse pour arrêter
des tourbières parce que le rôle naturel
est extrêmement important non seulement
pour les Canadiens les Canadiens mais
aussi pour l'ensemble de la planète
parce qu'on n'a pas de politique comme
ça jusqu'à maintenant ça existe pas au
niveau national il y a pas de politique
d'ensemble pour l'ensemble du Canada il
y a des discussions à l'intérieur des
des ministères
avant d'acheter regardez bien les
étiquettes de composition des sacs de
terreau pour vous assurer de l'absence
de tours
on est une époque on peut essayer de
trouver d'autres matériaux pour se
fabriquer d'autres terreaux différemment
fait
en Europe les règles sont plus strictes
principalement parce qu'ils restent très
peu de tourbières intacte là-bas en 2024
les terreaux contenant de la mousse de
tourbe seront bannis au Royaume-Uni
un mouvement Pitt free s'y répandu et
toutes sortes de produits de
remplacement sont arrivés sur le marché
à base de noix de coco ou de bois au
Canada les tourbières sont vus depuis
longtemps comme des ressources
naturelles et les ressources relèvent
des provinces mais des changements se
pointent le bout du nez
il y a des discussions beaucoup de
discussions actuellement il y a des
discussions entre le fédéral et
les gouvernements provinciaux de plus en
plus
il y a le gouvernement du Québec qui
s'est doté d'une politique de
conservation
des grands puits depuis naturels et
d'une politique de conservation du
carbone terrestre est-ce que ça explique
un peu pourquoi il y a des compagnies
qui voudraient aller chercher de la
tourbière ailleurs au Canada peut-être
c'est sûr que l'exploitation de
nouvelles tourbières va devenir de plus
en plus difficile
pour obtenir un feu vert l'Embar doit
soumettre une évaluation d'impact au
gouvernement ça sketchwanna mais Myriam
et son groupe ont demandé au ministère
fédéral de l'environnement d'évaluer la
situation en vertu de la Loi sur
l'évaluation environnementale le public
peut signaler un projet qui entraînerait
des effets négatifs sur un domaine de
compétences fédérale comme les cibles
nationales de réduction des gaz à effet
de serre par exemple ou si des peuples
autonomes sont affectés
actuellement une évaluation
environnementale qui comprend des
consultations des communautés sur place
il faudra attendre encore pour savoir si
le projet ira de l'avant ou non le
Conseil de banque de la ronge si est
déjà opposé fermement
je pense que mettre un
Aulas sur l'ouverture des terrains c'est
peut-être pas la bonne façon de faire en
ce moment l'industrie de la vie de façon
responsable je pense que c'est là-dessus
qu'il faut probablement amuser la
récolte de tourbe c'est juste une petite
partie de toutes les perturbations que
subissent les tourbières les sables
bitumineux les ont beaucoup gruger en
Ontario des minéraux essentiels aux
voitures électriques se cachent sous
d'immenses tourbières il y aura des
décisions difficiles à prendre dans les
prochaines années
comment trouver l'équilibre entre
tradition ressources milieu de vie et
protection de la nature de plus en plus
on se tourne vers les savoirs
autochtones pour résoudre ces casse-tête
en 2021 le gouvernement du Canada a
investi 340 millions de dollars dans des
projets de conservation de milieu
naturel menées par des autochtones dans
une optique de réconciliation oui mais
aussi parce que les premiers peuples
sont souvent les mieux placés pour
protéger les espèces menacées et les
réserves de carbone
que ce soit pour notre plaisir d'aller
ramasser du canneberge que ce soit pour
la connaissance de ces écosystèmes-là au
niveau scientifique que ce soit pour
l'industrie je pense que de valoriser de
prendre de pas prendre ça pour acquis
puis de faire une utilisation raisonnée
et sensée de la ressource je pense que
c'est ça la clé à chaque fois que je
choisis une tourbière c'est ce que je
retiens que je suis contente que ce soit
là puisqu'on fait bien les choses qu'on
devrait naturel
lever le drapeau pour arrêter
l'exploitation des tourbières le plus
possible surtout dans les territoires
nordiques dans des régions par exemple
notamment je pense au bois Saint-Laurent
ou sur la côte nord ou
l'industrie de la tourbe est un gang
pain important pour les communautés
régionales c'est toujours la difficulté
entre ne pas enlever le gang de pain des
gens et protéger la nature avec les
connaissances qu'on a maintenant il
faudrait juste une prévoyance par
rapport à la façon dont on utilise le
mieux naturel